for the first time the very first time
we have a detailed picture of what
happened in the 24 hours after an
asteroid hit the earth 65 million years
ago were you there dinosaurs do become
extinct as a joke
a research team led by the University of
Texas at Austin made the new discoveries
using rocks found off the Yucatan
Peninsula they say the blast ignited a
chaotic day of fires earthquakes and
tsunamis that doesn't sound fun leading
to a prolonged period of global cooling
their pizzas chief astronomer at the
Franklin Institute in Philadelphia good
morning when I said that doesn't sound
like fun you go well maybe it was very
exciting news for you
it is very exciting big deal why have
been great for geologists who have been
there to see what actually happened but
the reason why it's so exciting is
because here we have an instance in
which scientists can actually get a
really clear snapshot picture of what
happened that day this is the most
eventful day almost in the history of
the planet this thing was six miles wide
it created a crater 90 miles wide 18
miles deep and it blew up twenty five
trillion metric tons of material into
the atmosphere Wow so we're learning
more about our planets past does it tell
us something about the future well it
tells us that this is not something
that's isolated we can have asteroid
impacts in the future right now we know
there aren't any big asteroids that are
anywhere near us but small ones are
still around that could cause problems
for us you say it's all about location
location location it is because if the
asteroid did not had not hit that
particular location in and in time it
could have been a very different outcome
for the planet that particular impact
region at that particular time created
this world that we have now because it
altered the planet because of its impact
there if it had hit somewhere else we
could have had a different planet and
scientists have looked at different rock
deposit at the asteroids crater what if
they found in this evidence so what they
found in this evidence is that they know
that the planet was the way it was at
the time they know that this this huge
impact created a gigantic tidal wave
that washed across you know this
continent and
really change the face of the planet in
that in that location or really change
the face of the planet
overall entirely and you are an
astronomer you are confident that we
have running out of time or there's not
a big one out there heading our way
no I'm confident there is a big one
heading our way we do know that there
was here at Cal but we haven't been able
to identify anything big heading our way
and we've taken a very good assessment
of what's out there still more work to
be done all right we know there aren't
any more planet killers out there in the
next step I'm glad to hear that
it's thank you